community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners
finley automotive group southwest
medical part of optimum care and silver
state schools credit union
all right as the silver state schools
credit union celebrates their 70th year
of credit and community they have some
great news to share here's more
[Music]
silver state schools credit union has
had an excellent year we're celebrating
our 70th anniversary
with over 56 000 members and i have to
really give thanks
to our members and also our staff for
doing that uh some of the things that
we've done
this year in the first quarter is we've
actually achieved the one billion dollar
asset mark which is a tremendous
milestone for an organization such as
ours that's been in business for 70
years
we are doing continued community give
back
with continued pandemic support
and one of the fun things that we've
done this year and that we continue to
do every year
is to give 10 scholarships to deserving
high school seniors around
the valley and so that's a great thing
and the last thing i wanted to mention
too
is from a financial literacy perspective
it's probably never been more important
that we provide that kind of support to
the community here in southern nevada
so silver state schools credit union is
a great choice for a financial
institution
especially a primary financial
institution because we're a
not-for-profit organization and we're
here at our water street branch today
which is our newest branch
and we serve downtown henderson at this
branch and we're close to the government
offices
so it's perfect for accessibility
so what not for profit means is that we
have no shareholders we're actually
our members are the owners of this
organization
and so what that means to our members is
it provides lower loan rates
it also provides higher dividend rates
in general and
we offer all the premier banking
products that your normal banks do
i'd also like to mention that we have 10
branches geographically dispersed across
the valley and that really helps us
serve our members
and on top of that we have simple
convenient
and secure online and mobile banking
channels and and
that's probably one of the most
important things today is to have an
excellent channel
for online banking and so we do have
that
most importantly we prioritize people
over profit
now almost anyone can become a member of
silver state schools credit union
of course educators administrators and
staffs are all
eligible but also if you're school
volunteer or retiree
even if you're a student a parent or
guardian of an educational organization
throughout nevada you're eligible for
membership
one of my favorite ways of becoming a
member
that most people don't know about too is
making a one-time donation to vegas pbs
so silver state schools credit union is
doing great for not only our members but
the community at large
by all the things that we do again that
support
prioritizing people over profit